job's done on the first video game in
those days the programmers created the
sounds I think they wanted to create an
audience and cheers and at the end of
they were just not for the tone
definitely limited to the waveforms they
could made it enough samples so they had
a chip that made sounds they could only
get up to a certain pitch because that
took some horsepower away from the rest
of the game people have probably heard
that sound tens of thousands of times
and it's one little tone amazing it
starts creating tension inside a bunch
of games we're about to run out of time
so what did they do they make the music
playback faster that's one of the tricks
change rhythm to change speed that sound
increasing in frequency he timed that to
the human heartbeat around 60 beats per
minute something like that as that sound
got quicker his or her heart rate was
being affected as well that was probably
the first time a bit of psychoacoustics
was finding its way into game design the
sound of insatiability the name of the
game was called puck man we started with
the tone and now we modulated it so it's
not really bad when they brought that
over to the United States teenagers at
the time thought it would be funny if
they kind of blocked out the curvature
of the P as the pac-man is biting it the
sound mimicked that so closely man
in the day you can hear it in a
restaurant a bar end of it and you know
exactly what it was and so they changed
it from puck man to pac-man they wanted
to create a certain amount of emotion
with Donkey Kong there's this almost
hearkening to the way that cartoon
sounds behave so it's a little bit of
Carl stalling the composers to all the
bugs
buddy don't blow Flintstones off that's
all wood blocks and used orchestras then
cuz the sound effects weren't there okay
[Music]
defender probably had the most complex
sounds to that point well I say like I'm
the NES the actual RAM was like 128 K or
something like that one of those things
where they embrace the limitations that
they had the easiest waveform that will
come out of this process would be a
square wave but as you change what would
we call the duty cycle that is making it
more like a rectangle that's you know up
more than its down or down more that's
up that changes the tambour both when it
when it's static like that or when it's
moving over time that's when it gets
very interesting it's almost like a
planned demolition but there's also a
bit of what we what we call party at the
beginning of it there's that the game
boy had four channels of audio it was
even limited compared to the bigger
consoles three of them were just there
called PSG sounds like a bleep or a
bloop but again they had an oscillator
maybe could do F family could do a
little bit of modulation the fourth
channel was what's called white noise so
that was just like a if you made it
really low it sounded like an explosion
using modulating synthesizer
well it almost has a laughing quality
putting a little pitch shift in there to
kind of replicate it's kind of fun I
mean you know games tease you is that
the best you can do you know it was
something that was crafted with the
express intention to make you want to
shoot that dog unfortunately and you
were unloading as much as you could it's
the sound of progress
sound can often be just the perfect tool
to reassure you that you've accomplished
something if we feel like you failed we
use dissonance so we do just a consonant
it actually has sympathetic vibrations
you kind of start low and go high it's
the psychology of giving you that but
this is a transition sound it's not as
much a conic
but it serves the purpose from
transitioning going down the pipes
covers up the fact that hey they're
loading out a bunch of stuff in the back
and then they're loading in a bunch of
stuff in front of you or underneath you
your first and possibly most important
ability it tracks the motion and it's oh
well it has the feeling of elasticity
the very definition of interaction being
signaled by sound and like so many
things in music and design is just a
feels like yeah I think that works if I
go like this the attack is that that
first crack you hear Dan and what
they're doing
they're using a long attack on that
white noise to almost you know to
replicate something passing through the
air genius it felt really satisfying
because everything else was so tonal
around it and this was more broadband
[Music]
so they're once again using that long
lead-in for the attack this isn't one
bullet coming from one opening this is
something that's spreading I think what
they did was they had a lot of room to
be able to have their sounds kind of
take up a different portion of the
frequency spectrum the music kind of sat
in one area the sounds for impacts and
whatnot sat in another and the sounds
for your players gun sat in yet another
and I think that that was like kind of
the birthplace of us starting to get it
disappointment sound of Megaman died you
died all the time and meant that sound
just like it's just an abrupt halt we
are in an era now where probably at
least four things can be played at one
time out of the little speaker it's like
a slot machine but I'm wines come out
and everybody notices and it was
somebody one it's the same psychological
feel with this I think everybody kind of
tries to imitate that sound in one way
or another when they're trying to create
pickup sounds it's that sound that you
get you're like okay you did a good
thing the collection sounds we're always
the toughest sounds to do from a sound
design standpoint video games started
having dedicated sound chips everything
was given a priority between 0 and 127
the ring sounds would always get the
highest priority the palette just got
finger there's a theorem called the
Nyquist and that essentially says in
order for a sound to be able to have
audible frequencies above a certain
amount it has to have twice so much of
the sample rate if you hear on that
sound not only is it resampled to be
smaller the bitrate of it is also a lot
smaller as well in order to fit it in
the memory what these sounds do is give
presents they start giving the
characters of voice Hadouken from
Japanese literally translates to wave
motion fist Sonic branding is what they
did with this it just felt like it just
swept over the entire world really fast
Russia this is like government running
books and and you know showing Elvis
from the waist up this is like the video
game equivalent of that it gets the
testosterone going its battle its Mortal
Kombat it brought the quieter parts and
it made them louder about the latter
parts and amazing quieter
about the volume up of that so they
basically they compress the dynamic
range of the sound and then they added a
bit of reverb on it but I think that the
most convincing portion of this is the
performance and I think that's something
that we don't have an effect for yet and
I don't think we ever will when this one
tone gets to this one portion that's
when I start holding accelerate so that
I can get a speed boost at the start
certain sounds that are less iconic but
they service the product it's the sound
that gets your attention so that's why
ambulances and sirens have you know
that's why they're there sirens go off
they're down over time it's how we're
wired as humans yeah those are
terrifying at the time everyone wanted
to use sampled sounds but there'd be a
budget of memory you get real creative
how you Jam all those sounds in there
and how to make a 1/4 second long barely
telephone fidelity sound still have the
impact you want it sound like something
frightening this is the beginning of
positional audio should I move you in a
direction should I not move the in
aggression now sound starts entering
into the world of gameplay and not just
a motion that is clearly the linking
sound from midst there was nothing
better in the game than finding a new
linking book sampled sound effects all
made with traditional recording
techniques you go on these journeys for
hours and hours and then when you get to
the payoff the sound is part of that
payoff as a spender a wrench hit it with
another wrench and then slow that down
and that became the clock chime these
are the kinds of things that we would do
every day for television and film and
was finally happening in games
bravi so this is a game that I worked on
earthworm jim this is almost like a
cartoon coming to life all he would do
is try to make each other laugh we
didn't have any game design document we
didn't have producers looking over our
shoulders sometimes it's an actor and
somebody sometimes it's somebody in the
office that just gets goofy wait a
minute I like what you said say that
again let me record it you record it you
put it in that voice that you hear is
the designer of the game
to Napal
you try to create sounds for things that
don't really exist I think the best
thing you can do is try to figure out
the intention of it first
I love the Resident Evil games but they
are known for like you know some of the
worst voice acting ever in the history
of video games but we love it because
it's Resident Evil and it's endearing to
us oh this is a zombie okay so what
portions of it do we need to focus on
you know it's trying to make something
that's universally thought of as a
zombie Pokemon and from the gameboy
version the original everyone's favorite
I think the last part is basically noise
picking up stuff selecting things in a
menu those are kind of more the bleep
and bloopy type of things in FM you make
it go so fast it starts getting a
metallic tone and it ends with creates
finality and it services the end so the
challenge of doing a menu sound those
are some of the toughest sounds as well
because this is something that the
player is going to hear hundreds of
thousands of times Final Fantasy is one
of those franchises that's known for its
music it's really underscore gives you
that emotion like a normal score would
in any other medium that sense of
accomplishment that fanfare trumpets
everywhere the banners flying victory
that's what that is
definitely proved to be timeless shows
up in a lot of concerts played by
symphony orchestras these days I played
metal gear on the original NES it was
really hard getting spotted by people
happen all the time the gigs up you've
been made it's startling it's kind of
like the beginning of a siren every
meeting we work in everyone has
aspirations from somewhere it's no
secret that Hideo Kojima's is evalee
influenced by you know like movies and
television it's like an orchestra
playing like a stinger like buddy
the attack is right in your face what
the decay is cut really short sent you
in a state of panic still happens with
guns of the Patriots still happens with
the phantom pain even essentially it's
rooted in that past
[Music]